the Justice Department's anti-terrorism
advisory council and the US intelligence
community. He has discussed jihad,
Islam, and terrorism at a workshop
sponsored by the US State Department and
German foreign ministry. He he is a
consultant for the center for security
policy and the vice president of the
American Freedom Defense Initiative.
Spencer is a weekly columnist for PJ
Media and Front Page Magazine and has
written hundreds of articles about jihad
and Islamic terrorism. His articles on
Islam and other topics appeared in the
Los Angeles Times, the San Francisco
Examiner, the New York Post, the
Washington Times, the Dallas Morning
News, Fox News Opinion, National Review,
The Hill, The Detroit News, Town
Hall.com, Real Clear Religion, The Daily
Caller, The New Criterion, The Journal
of International Security Affairs, The
UK's Guardian, Canada's National Post,
Middle East Quarterly, World Daily or
World Net Daily, First Things, Inside in
the News, and many other journals. For
nearly 10 years, Vincer wrote the weekly
jihad watch column at Freeman events. He
also served as a contributing writer to
the investigative project on terrorism
and as an adject fellow for the free
congress free congress
foundation. Spencer has appeared on a
huge number of news outlets. just a few
including the BBC, ABC News, CNN, Fox
News, The O'Reilly Factor, Megan Kelly's
The Kelly File, The Sean Hannity Show,
PBS, MSNBC, CNBC, C-SPAN, CTV News,
France 24, Voice of Russia, Croatia
National Television, and many others. We
are thrilled to have him here with us
tonight. So, it is my honor to welcome
Robert Spencer.
Thank you. I uh am very honored to be
here and I want to thank especially the
college Republicans for braving all the
approprium and bringing such a
villainous character as I to the campus
this evening and I am grateful for all
the people who are here to have a civil
discussion. It is very difficult
nowadays to have a civil discussion and
a lot of people think that I ought not
to have been afforded this platform to
have a discussion about these issues
because they have claimed I have seen in
the last week or so that I do not make
the necessary distinction between
Muslims and terrorists and supposedly
demonize all Muslims in a way that
endangers innocent people. Now this is a
false charge but actually something
quite like it is really going on. What's
actually going on is that there is a
conflation a distinction that is not
being made not between Muslims and
terrorists. The distinction that is not
being made is between legitimate
criticism of an analysis of the
motivating ideology of jihad
terrorists and those people who are
actually actually genuinely racists and
bigots. And any analysis of that
motivating ideology of the jihad
terrorists is all too often consigned to
the realms of racism and bigotry in a
way that is actively deletious to the
ability of free nations and free
individuals to oppose and resist that
terrorism. I'll give you a case in
point. About 10 years ago, there was a
jihad plot at Fort Dicks in New Jersey.
And there was a group of Muslims who
were going to go into Fort Dicks and
shoot up the place, kill as many
American soldiers as possible before
they themselves would be killed. The
plot, however, was foiled. And it was
foiled in a very interesting way. It
turns out that these jihadis, they were
after all jihadis. And as jihadis
themselves often remind us, they love
death. They love death. They have often
said, Jokart Sarna, one of the Boston
Marathon bombers, and many others have
said, "We will win because we love death
more than you love life." So these
jihadis, they loved death and they loved
to watch death videos, beheading videos,
war videos, all sorts of bloodshed and
gore. But the problem was, this was 10
years ago, more than that now. They had
them on VHS
tapes. And so they went to a video store
in Jersey and asked the guy to transfer
their VHS tapes of jihad bloodshed to
DVD. And I I don't know. I never worked
in a video store. I don't know how it
works, but apparently he had to watch
this young man, 17 years old, he had to
watch the videos in order in the process
of transferring them. And he was very
disturbed by what he
saw. Yet 17-year-old young man named
Brian Morgan Stern and he went to his
boss and he said,
"Dude, I'm seeing some very disturbing
[__] on these
videos. Should I call the police or
would that be
racist? Should I call the police or
would that be racist? Now, I should note
at this point that the jihadis in
question were Albanian Muslims from
Kosovo who were all white guys. They
were white Europeans.
And yet he had internalized to such a
degree the idea that even resistance to
people who were going to commit mass
murder, resistance, opposition to trying
to thwart people who were going to try
to kill as many human beings as they
possibly could. That somehow that would
be wrong, that somehow that would be
racist. And so he almost didn't do it.
We can all be grateful that he decided
to go ahead and be racist and to brave
the approprium that he thought might
come to him for reporting these
men. Now this was the result. Where did
he get this idea? He got this idea from
day after day, week after week, year
after year being told that if you talk
about how jihadis use the texts and the
teachings of Islam to justify violence
and to make recruits among peaceful
Muslims, then you are part of the
problem. you are part of the
Islamophobia
industry that is creating fear and
hatred of
Muslims when in reality if there is any
unjustified suspicion of Islam among any
non-Muslims Americans or
non-Americans then it is the result of
terrorist
attacks I mean I appreciate the tribute
that the previous speaker gave gave to
me in contributing to me such power that
I would be able to manipulate the
American people into fearing and hating
Muslims. But I ain't that good. It was
not I who did this. If anybody fears and
hates Muslims, that's unfortunate. But
the people who are responsible are Nidal
Malik Kasan, the Fort Hood jihad
massacre shooter. Jokar and Tamarind
Sarnay, the Boston Marathon bombers,
Tashi Malik and Sed Rswan Farukq, who
killed 15 people at a Christmas party in
San Bernardino in December 2015.
Muhammad Aziz who killed four Marines in
Chattanooga. And so many
others. People see what's happening and
they don't understand why it's happening
in particular because they are told that
if they take what the jihadis say and
listen to them and they hear them
crying and they hear them quoting the
Quran and repeating what it says as a
justification for their acts, then
there's something wrong with them. then
they're racist and evil and
bigoted and no doubt making millions in
the process. I found out tonight that
I'm a millionaire. That's very
interesting. But unfortunately, none of
that is true. And all these things are
based on distortions and halftruths that
have intimidated and manipulated all too
many people into thinking that it's a
terrible thing to stand up against mass
murder and oppression and religiously
sanctioned violence. Now
obviously not all Muslims believe this.
This is absolutely true. It was claimed
in this previous talk that the
understanding of Islam that I'm going to
give you is the same as the
understanding of Islam that Osama bin
Laden would give you were he here
tonight or Abu Bakr aldatti the caiff of
the Islamic State who it was claimed had
no religious training. Actually Abu Bakr
al Baghdaddy has a PhD in Islamic
studies from the University of
Baghdad.
Actually, I'd like to set your mind at
ease about that. I'm not going to give
you my understanding of Islam at all. My
understanding of Islam is completely
unimportant and irrelevant. The
understanding of Islam that every person
of goodwill who opposes terrorism,
Muslim or non-Muslim, the understanding
of Islam that every such person needs to
be concerned about is the understanding
of Islam that the jihad terrorists are
indeed
spreading and it is unfortunately not
their own
invention. I have
here several authorities.
One of
them
is a Quran. I got this in London in
2009. You may have heard Mr. Sed say
that I was not I'm not allowed to go
into Britain and that's quite true. But
he was actually quite wrong in saying
that I was barred from Britain for being
an
extremist. Uh I do have an extreme love
for certain kinds of foods, but that's
about it. Uh there was no mention in the
letter. I was sitting in my office one
day and FedEx came up and they gave me
this uh certified letter and I had to
sign for it and even the FedEx guy was
impressed. He said it's from the British
government and the British government
wrote to me and they said don't come. We
won't let you in. And this is why they
said it. They said because you said
Islam has a doctrine and theology and
legal system mandating warfare against
unbelievers. Therefore, you were not
allowed to come in. The same week that
they barred me from Britain for saying
that Islam has a doctrine of warfare
against unbelievers, they let in
Muhammad Alari, who is a Saudi sh who
has said that jihad involves the
smashing of the skulls and the spilling
of the blood of the
infidels. Clearly, Muhammad Alifi
believes that ji Islam has a doctrine of
warfare against unbelievers. But that
was okay with the British government.
It was not okay with the British
government for me to say it. The
difference is apparently you can get
into Britain if you're for it, but not
if you're against it. Of course, the
British government has to deal with the
very large and increasingly restive
Muslim population. And so, one might
understand why that is so, but I
digress. In 2009, before the ban, I went
to London and I was there on business,
but I had some free time and so I did
what any tourist in London would do, any
American tourist. I toured the local
mosques. So, I went to the Finsbury Park
Mosque in London, which was the mosque
of Abu Hamza al- Masu, who was uh you
may have seen pictures of him. He's very
fearsome looking character. He uh was
making a bomb once and he blew off his
hands and put up one of his eyes and so
he has two hooks for hands and one of
his eyes has no pupil and he was the
imam at the Finsbury Park Mosque but he
was ultimately removed from there and
imprisoned for various jihad plotting.
He was trying to establish an al-Qaeda
training camp in Oregon and so he's now
imprisoned in the United States, but the
Finsbury Park mosque remains. I went
there in '09 after he was gone. And I
said to the very kind young man who was
there, and he was weighing me down with
books. He gave me a lot of wonderful
books, including this edition of the
Quran. And I said, "I understand there
was a little bit of trouble here a few
years back." and he said, "Yes, there
were some extremists here, but now
they're all gone and we're all
moderates." And so he gave me this
moderate Quran. This Quran is very uh
useful because it has commentary by Say
Abu Alam Maldudi who was a Pakistani
Islamic scholar and politician. He's the
founder of Jamaat Islami, which is still
the largest Islamist political party in
Pakistan. He also wrote a multi-olume
commentary on the Quran. And I know that
the Muslims here can attest. If you go
to any Islamic
bookstore, brick and mortar or online,
you will find Maudi's writings,
including his commentary on the Quran.
In other words, he's not considered an
extremist. He's very
mainstream. And so, let's take
Mauudi for example on chapter 9 29.
Chapter 9:29 of the Quran says, "Fight
those who do not obey Allah and his
messenger, and do not forbid what he has
forbidden, even if they are of the
people of the book, which is primarily
Jews and Christians, until they pay the
Jiza, which is a tax, with willing
submission and feel themselves subdued."
Now, you don't have to pay any attention
to what I think about that passage.
Let's go to Maldudi. Mudi says the
purpose for which the Muslims are
required to fight required to fight is
not as one might think to compel the
unbelievers into embracing Islam. Okay.
So the fighting is not about forced
conversion. Very good. But what is it
for? Rather its purpose is to put an end
to the suzaranti the rule of the
unbelievers so that the latter the
unbelievers are unable to rule over
people. Did you get that? I'll repeat
that. Its purpose is to put an end to
the suzaranti of the unbelievers so that
the latter are unable to rule over
people, not just some people, not just
the people who have uh stolen land or
oppressed the Muslims or something of
that kind. But it's an open-ended thing.
Unbelievers are not to be invested with
political power. He goes on to say, "The
authority to rule should only be vested
in those who follow the true faith.
Unbelievers who do not follow this true
faith should live in a state of
subordination. Anybody who becomes
convinced of the truth of Islam may
accept the faith of his or her own
valition. The unbelievers are required
to pay the Jiza the pole tax in return
for the security provided to them as the
duties the protected people of the
Islamic state. Jiza symbolizes the
submission of the unbelievers to the
suzari of Islam. So in other words,
there's no idea of equality of rights
for all, but this is a very clear hier
hierarchy where the Muslims rule and the
non-Muslims submit and pay this tax and
show that they are in subordination to
the Muslims. And Mudi is saying that
that is the purpose for which the
Muslims are required to fight.
Now obviously he's not the only Islamic
scholar and there are many many other
voices that say many many other things.
The problem here is the people who do
believe him and the people who do agree
with him because once again he is not
some kind of extremist. He was not a
member of a terrorist group. He did not
pick up a gun and shoot people. He was a
politician and an Islamic
scholar. Mr. Messiah noted he made a
great deal of the fact that there are
Christians in Egypt. There are not not
actually Catholics. They're Coptic
Orthodox. But in any case, the Coptic
Orthodox churches that were bombed the
other day do indicate that they've been
Christians in Egypt from the 7th
century, the time that the Muslims
conquered Egypt up until today. So
that's very impressive. Mr. society
would have us believe that that means
that Islam is tolerant and does not
mandate the conquest of the unbelievers
or presumably all those Christians would
be gone. Let's look at that in
historical perspective. Egypt when it
was conquered in the early 640s late
630s early 640s by the Arab armies it
was 99% Christian. Today it is between 6
to 10% Christian. Where did all those
Christians go? Did they leave? Some did,
but most of them stayed. It wasn't so
easy up until modern times to be mobile,
to move halfway across the world,
whatever. The Christians of Egypt are
still there. They're the
Muslims. Did they convert because of the
compelling nature of the message of
Islam that they saw to be superior to
that of Christianity? Obviously, some of
them must have. At the same time, the
Christians had to pay a crushing tax.
This Jizio, some of the early records
have some of the Christian families
having to sell their children to get the
money to pay this tax.
And they had to live with various
humiliating and discriminatory
regulations which still m remain part of
Islamic law, Sharia or Sharia as Mr.
society likes to call
it. One of them was that they can't
build new houses of worship or repair
old ones. And so that means obviously
your community is always in a state of
decline. There have been some riots and
some very very unpleasant situations in
Egypt quite recently because Christians
were trying to build a church and the
Muslims there consider this is against
Islamic law. Christians are not allowed
to build a church and so they have to be
forcibly stopped from doing so and they
were. They cannot hold authority over
Muslims. So they can only hold the most
menial jobs in society. At every turn
they have to, for example, like in the
old Jim Crow South, they have to step
off the sidewalk if a Muslim is coming.
They have to be always reminded of their
subordinate state. But there was one way
you could get out of this just like that
and be treated like everybody else and
that was to convert to Islam. Over the
14th centuries intervening, most of the
Christians did indeed do that. It's just
human nature. However much they may have
valued the Christian faith. At the same
time, it's miserable to live under those
laws. Now, you might say, well, you're
extrapolating. These are laws that came
about because of various political or
historical circumstances that actually
have nothing to do with Islamic law. So
I brought another
book so that you wouldn't have to
believe such a villainous fellow as I.
You can believe alazar. Alazar in Cairo
is the foremost institution in Sunni
Islam. Islam has no central authority,
no pope, but the closest thing to it in
terms of influence and prestige is
Alazar. Barack Obama when he gave his
outreach speech to the Islamic world on
June 4th, 2009, he spoke at Alazar in
Cairo and he praised it as a bastion of
learning and of intellectual exploration
for over a thousand years.
This is a manual of Islamic law. It's a
very handy one volume manual of Islamic
law and it carries in the beginning of
it a certification from
Alazar. And the certification says
that
this we certify that the abovementioned
translation obviously I'm reading this
in English. We are speaking English
tonight. The abovementioned translation
corresponds to the Arabic original
that's one and conforms to the practice
and faith of the orthodox Sunni
community. Sunnis are 85% roughly of
Muslims worldwide and the al-Assar the
foremost institution in Sunni Islam is
saying that this book conforms to the
practice and faith of the Orthodox Sunni
community. In other words, you want to
know what Sunni Islam is all about?
It's in this book. It also carries
certifications, endorsements from the
MUI of the Jordanian Armed Forces, the
International Institute of Islamic
Thought, which is a prominent
organization in the United States as
well as worldwide, and actually came up
with the whole idea of
Islamophobia. It's
uh Islamophobia was coined. It's a word
that's been used here and there since
the beginning of the 20th century, but
it was chosen at a meeting of the
International Institute of Islamic
Thought uh as being something that would
be intentionally used to intimidate
people into thinking there was something
wrong with resisting jihad terror. And
the problem is here again important
distinctions are not made. There are
attacks against innocent people and like
the burning down of the mosque in Joplin
and so on. Well, that's reprehensible
and there's no excuse for that and no
sane person would justify it. And if
that's Islamophobia, then obviously
everybody's against it. But also under
the rubric of Islamophobia, as I pointed
out earlier, is the attempts to
understand the motives and the goals of
the jihad terrorists so that they can be
resisted more effectively. So anyway,
this
book certified by some of the highest
authorities in Sunni Islam, including
Alazar, and this is what it says.
It says jihad means to war against
non-Muslims. Jihad means to war against
non-Muslims. It does go on to say that
that's the lesser jihad. The lesser
jihad is warfare and the greater jihad
as Mr. Saiad pointed out is the
spiritual struggle within the soul to
become a better person.
This manual of Islamic law dismisses
that greater jihad in that single
paragraph and then goes on for about 10
pages giving rules about the lesser
jihad quoting the Quran saying fighting
is prescribed for you. That's surah 2
verse 216. Kill them wherever you find
them. Surah 4:89. That's also in 21 that
he put up and also chapter 9:5 the verse
of the sword. Fight the idolattors
utterly. Chapter 9:36. It then quotes
some hadits. Hadits are reports about
Muhammad's words and deeds. When
considered authentic by Islamic
scholars, then they're normative for
Islamic law. So obviously these are
authentic hadiths or they would not be
certified by alazar. Muhammad says, I
have been commanded to fight people
until they testify that there is no god
but Allah and that Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah and perform the
prayer and pay zaka. If they say it,
they have saved their blood and
possessions from me except for the
rights of Islam over them. So if they
say there is no god but Allah and
Muhammad is his messenger, their blood
and possessions are
safe. Therefore, if they don't say it,
their blood and possessions are not
safe.
goes on quoting war
had it says
that the caiff makes war upon Jews,
Christians and Zoroastrians provided he
has first invited them to enter Islam in
faith and practice and if they will not
then invited them to enter the social
order of Islam by paying the non-Muslim
pole tax jiza which is the significance
of their paying it and the war continues
until they become Muslim or else pay the
non-Muslim pole tax and Then it quotes
chapter 9 29 which I quoted to you
earlier. It goes on to say that once the
war has been successfully
completed and the non-Muslims have been
defeated then they take on the status of
the demise the protected people. Now
protected people is the name but you
have to understand what that protection
is
like. You may recall stories about the
mafia and the mafia would go to a
storefront and they would go in and see
the storekeeper and they would say, "You
got a very nice place
here. This beautiful little store you
got here. You know, it' be a shame if a
rock came through that window. I can
make sure that doesn't happen for you if
you pay me $100 a week." That's
protection. You pay protection, you
don't get victimized.
The same thing here the minimum
non-Muslim pole tax is one dinar that is
4.235 gram of gold per person and so on
and then the non-Muslims are
distinguished from Muslims in the US and
the reason for that comes in the next
provision. They are not greeted with
assalamu alaykum peace be upon you. They
are greeted with the greeting peace be
upon those who are rightly guided that
is the Muslims. They must keep to the
side of the street. They may not build
higher or as high than the Muslims
buildings. And they are forbidden to
openly display wine or pork to ring
church bells or display crosses, recite
the Torah or gospel aloud, or make
public display of their funerals and
feast days and are forbidden to build
new
churches. If they violate these
agreements in any way, then their lives
are forfeit. or if they insult Islam or
Muhammad, then their lives are forfeit.
So these things are part of classic
traditional Islamic law from mainstream
sources. They are not the twisted,
hijacked understanding of Islam that
vicious Islamophobes like Spencer are
trying to pass off as the real thing.
You got to wonder about a motive there
since there really isn't a whole lot of
money in this and there's a great deal
of risk. Mr. Sad praised the police, but
the police are here because I was
threatened. The police are here because
it was out on Twitter, bash the fetch
because of course it's fascist to oppose
jihad mass murder. And the police are
here because people were saying punch
Spencer's face. They were not here for
Mr. Scad's protection. Although I am
very glad that they were here in case
that there was any rogue Islamophobe who
might have dared to accost him that they
were here for his protection as well.
But the reality is that this
is a concerted
effort to demonize and stigmatize,
marginalize and thereby silence anybody
who speaks honestly about the nature the
the the sources and the derivation of
Islamic terrorism with the obvious
object of clearing away obstacles to
Islam. ic terrorism so that it can
advance unimpeded and unopposed. Brian
Morgan Stern, the young man in New
Jersey, was afraid that if he turned in
the jihad killers, he would be a racist.
And there are many, many other people
who feel the same way. Say Rizwan Farukq
and Kashi Malik, the San Bernardino
shooters. After they killed all those
people at the Christmas party, their
neighbors said, "Well, you know, they
were acting very suspiciously." And
there were people coming and going all
night. And we thought that something
wrong was going on there. And the
obvious question followed. Did you call
the police? No. Why didn't you call the
police? Well, we wouldn't want to appear
to be racist or
xenophobic. And this is the kind of
number that's been done on anyone who
has an honest analysis of this. Now,
what is the background of that
initiative? Mr. Sad noted that very
proudly that he is a representative of
the Council on American Islamic
Relations. The Council on American
Islamic Relations, he said, is a big
target of right-wing extremists who say
that it sucks
women.
Actually, as a foremost person accused
of being a right-wing extremist, I can
tell you that I've never said that care
sucks. Never said I hate care or any of
this nonsense. The reality is is that I
oppose care because
care is a is a care is a front group for
Hamas and Hamas is a terror group that
actually celebrates the murders of
civilians in Israel and elsewhere. And I
see people Yes, it's terrible. It's
ludicrous to say that care is a front
for Abas except it was established by
the Justice Department of the United
States. The Justice Department of the
United States noted that Omar Akhmed and
Nihad Aawad were the co-founders of
care. They came from the Islamic
Association for Palestine, which was
closed down for being a front group for
Hamas. And that there was an
investigation of care going on in 2009
that was quashed by the Obama
administration for reasons that is never
disclosed. But there's quite a bit more.
Nihad Awad the co-founder of care he has
on record saying I am in support of the
Hamas movement he said that at Barry
University and Omar Akmed the his
co-founder in 1998 he said at its speech
in California that the Quran is is
Muslims are not in the United States to
coexist with other religions. Muslims
are in the United States to become
dominant and make the Quran the only law
of the land. He was speaking to a group
of Muslims. He didn't know that there
was a reporter there, a non-Muslim
reporter. She was not an Islamophobe.
She was not a right-wing extremist. She
was just a reporter for the local paper,
Lisa Gardner of the Fremont
Argus. And she reported what he said and
nothing
happened. About five, six years later,
people somebody noticed. I think it was
Daniel Pipes or somebody noticed that
Akmed had said this and began to
publicize it. And it was only then that
Omar Akmed said, "I never said that."
And Lisa Gardner of the Fremont Argus
was found and she said, "I heard him say
it. Stand I stand by the story." She did
not have any racist or Islamophobic
ulterior motive. She was simply
reporting what she had heard. She was
not informed about these matters. Was
not an ideologue, was not an activist.
She was just a reporter.
In 2007, the Holyland Foundation was
raided. The Holyland Foundation was at
that time the largest Islamic charity in
the United States. After a trial, it was
shut down for funneling charitable
contributions to Hamas.
At the time that it was
uh put on
trial, at a time that it began to be put
under investigation, the FBI raided the
offices of the Holy Land Foundation.
They carted away all these documents.
One of the
documents was entitled the strategic
goal for the Muslim Brotherhood in the
United States.
And it was written by Muhammad Akram who
was indeed a very high up Muslim
Brotherhood
leader. And it was it said that the
brothers must understand and I quote
that their work in America is a kind of
grand jihad in eliminating and
destroying Western civilization from
within and sabotaging its miserable
house by their hands and the hands of
the believers. see sabotaging the
miserable house of the West by their own
hands, getting non-Muslims in the West
to help sabotage their own
house, eliminating and destroying
Western civilization from within and
sabotaging its miserable house by their
hands and the hands of the believers so
that it falls and a lost religion is
victorious over other religions. I
didn't write that. That was from this
Muslim Brotherhood document that was
found in the Holy Land Foundation
reigns. The Holyland Foundation
document, the Muslim Brotherhood
document rather, also contained a list
of allied Muslim Brotherhood
organizations including the Islamic
Society of North America, the Muslim
Students Association, the uh Muslim
American Society, the International
Institute of Islamic Thought that
certified that book, and the Islamic
Association for Palestine from which
comes care. And so you have a number of
indications that it might be the motives
of these people who are telling you
these things and they sound so good and
the presentation is very slick and it
all sounds so
entertaining. The motive might be
something quite different. Now it may be
care of course denies all this but as I
say certified by the justice department
as an unindicted co-conspirator in the
Holyland trial foundation
case and the Holyland Foundation was
funing money to
Hamas. At least the question needs to be
raised. What is exactly the imperative
here?
care has opposed virtually every
counterterror measure that has been
implemented, including a perfectly legal
surveillance project that was certified
by several judges as being completely
constitutional in New York City in uh
various other places as well. There have
been perfectly reasonable programs shut
down on the grounds that they're
supposedly racist and bigoted. Now
certainly there are Muslims who oppose
jihad terror. Certainly there are
Muslims who are not on in line with this
program.
But when you have a group with multiple
ties to a terrorist organization, when
you have a group that has obstructed
counterterror efforts in numerous ways,
I had a friend went to K's
uh conference in Florida in Tampa and
sent me some photos of some of the
brochures that were out on the table and
they were uh what to do when the FBI
comes and it was a picture of the sh
symbol And of course in care San
Francisco they distributed posters
saying don't talk to the
FBI. So when you talk about you know
what what do you expect us to do? Well I
do expect cooperation with law
enforcement efforts. Yeah. And not
council to people not to cooperate with
law enforcement efforts. And when you
have that kind of thing then you got to
wonder what's going on here. And there's
more. What else? What do you expect us
to do? I'll give you an idea. How about
this? There is a worldwide
problem. It's been completely obscured
by these bogus charges of racism and
Islamophobia and so on, but there is a
worldwide problem. 30,000 plus jihad
terror attacks resulting in fatalities
around the world since
9/11. That's a massive problem.
same number. As a matter of fact, 30,000
young Muslims from around the world from
a 100 countries went to Iraq and Syria
to join ISIS because they believed in
its claims to be the caliphate, the sole
legitimate government for Sunni
Muslim.
Now, 30,000 people somehow got it all
wrong and many of them were Americans.
There has been a big problem in the
Minneapolis St. Paul area of young
Muslims first going back to Somalia
where many of them were from to join Ash
Shabbab, the jihad terror group and then
later when ISIS was formed going to Iraq
and Syria to join the Islamic State. It
is a huge problem that Minneapolis
officials have tried to address in
various ways. But there's one glaring
omission and that is that there's not a
single mosque in the Minneapolis area or
anywhere else that has any kind of
program to teach young Muslims why they
should reject the understanding of Islam
offered by al-Qaeda, ISIS, ashab and so
on. Now this is a very strange omission
again. You want to know what what one
can do? Well, why don't we start some
classes and say this is all wrong. It's
very easy to come to a university and
tell a lot of non-Muslims that Islam
doesn't really stand for all that, but
it's not going to prevent the next
terror attack. What needs to be done is
to go to the Muslims who believe in this
understanding of Islam. And if you're
sincere about opposing it then and
sincere about saying that it's not
actually the correct interpretation of
Islam, then give them a different
understanding and teach them why it's
wrong. But that we don't see happening.
Why
not? What is it that is really going on
here? In all the
demonization of me and other people that
I work with and all the lies that are
told about us and all the false claims
that are made about us, what is the
point? What is the endgame? These
comparisons with the way that the
Catholics and Jews were mistreated in
the United States of the past omits
several important factors. One was there
was not an international organization of
Catholics or Jews boasting about how
they were going to sew mayhem and
calling upon believers in the United
States to kill innocent civilians. There
was not an organization of Catholics or
Jews within the country that was
obstructing efforts to stop those
people. There was not an organization in
the United States that was attached to a
Catholic or Jewish terrorist group
outside the
country. So here we again come back to
where I began. If there is any
Islamophobia, understand me what I mean.
Obviously there are sometimes attacks on
innocent Muslims and that is always to
be rejected and always to be opposed.
But if by Islamophobia is meant, a
reading of the texts that I read to you
tonight and many many others like them
and an attempt to understand what
motivates and what is the goal of the
terrorists so that we can resist them
more effectively. What is the endgame of
foreclosing on that and saying that it's
all racist, it's all hateful, it's all
bigoted, it's all just like
anti-atholicism and no nothingism of the
1850s. What's the point?
If I am no longer allowed to speak
anywhere, which is pretty much nearly
the case now, and if I'm banned from
every country in the world, and if all
the wicked people like me go away, what
happens? Will the jihad stop? It will
not. Will the texts that motivate the
jihad go away? They will not.
What will happen if all of you came to
hear hate speech so that you could go
away feeling righteous and if you have
satisfied yourself that what I have told
you is indeed hate speech. Then what
happens then?
the next time that there is a jihad
terror attack by somebody screaming lak
rakbar and somebody who has quotations
from the Quran and on his Facebook page
and he has indicated that he is very
pious. For example, the guy that uh
tried to kill us in Texas when we held
our free speech event there a couple
years back. Ibrahim Simpson uh he came
from the mosque in Phoenix drove all the
way to Garland, Texas to get us. And uh
he one of his friends at the mosque said
he practically lived here. He would
sleep here. He never did anything that
the mosques that the mosque's leaders
didn't want.
So if all opposition to that is is
cleared
away then what happens the next time it
goes on and people try to understand it
and to deal with it in an effective way
then there's nobody left to do that.
There is no one who can
analyze the problem effectively. The
idea that this is all because of
American political actions in the Middle
East not does not take into account the
fact that the jihad is a lot older than
the United States of
America. And in the 7th century when the
invading armies conquered the Middle
East and North Africa and amassed within
a 100 years an empire stretching from
Spain to
India. They were not reacting to the
provocations of some superior power.
They were the superior power. There were
two great powers before the advent of
Islam, the Byzantine Empire and the
Persian Empire. But they were both
exhausted. They had been fighting so
many wars against each other that they
didn't have enough troops anymore to
withstand
anything. The last battle that Muhammad
fought wasn't really a battle at all.
Battle of Tabuk when he went up to Tabuk
in northern Arabia or southern Syria
depending on where you draw the border
and he was trying to attack the
Byzantine garrison there but there were
no Byzantines and there were no
Byzantines because they didn't have
enough troops to staff all their
garrisons so they would move from one to
the other along the borderlands. Well,
that's obviously an empire right for
collapse and it did collapse. It lasted
for several hundred more years but in a
vastly diminished form. The Persian
Empire, same thing, was exhausted. These
things were, these jihads were not the
result of reaction to aggression by
other powers. The other powers were not
bothering the Arabs in Arabia. They
couldn't possibly have done so if they
wanted
to. These jihads came about because of
teachings of the Quran and teachings of
Muhammad. I've been commanded to fight
against people until they confess that
there is no God but Allah and I am his
messenger. or the Quran 8:39. Fight
until religion is all for
Allah. All these things have to be
addressed by people of goodwill, Muslim
and non-Muslim.
And demonizing the people who ask the
questions that need to be asked is
counterproductive and ultimately only is
going to
serve to obscure the real problems that
we have and make it impossible for us to
address them.
In 2000 from 2005 to 2010, I regularly
would instruct the FBI and military
groups on Islam. I would give them an
idea of the mindset of the terrorists.
That's what it was all about. What do
they think? Because it's an adage as old
as warfare. You can't defeat an enemy
you don't understand. So I take them
through the Quran. Take them through the
life of Muhammad. In 2011, because
Muslim groups complained, I was removed
from this position, as were others. And
all mention of Islam and jihad was taken
out of counterterror training. So now,
if you were to join the FBI tomorrow,
you'll learn about right-wing extremists
and militia men and so on. You won't
hear a word about Islam or jihad. does
not exist in the countering violent
extremism program that Obama developed
and that is still in place at this
point. Now, that is a recipe for
disaster. You cannot defeat an enemy you
don't understand. And Muslims who
genuinely reject that understanding of
Islam should have no problem standing
with us and helping to fight against it.
That's all this is about. That's all my
work has been about all these years. And
that is all that I am trying to do as I
continue to write and speak. And thank
you for hearing me out. If you have any
questions, I will take them
[Applause]
now. All right. So, how we're going to
do this is the same as the last speaker.
I'll come to you. I'll hold the
microphone. Um, please keep in mind just
to keep it um short and concise and only
ask one question. If you have another
question, uh, re raise your hand. I'll
come back to you. But we just want to
get to as many people as possible.
Hello sir, my name is Xavier. Uh, a few
years ago, Phil Phil Robinson, the Duck
Dynasty guy, he was quoted on Fox News
as saying that non-Christians ought to
be converted or killed. My biggest
question for you is why are we focusing
solely on Islam or why you in particular
I suppose focus solely on Islam when
there are bad apples in every bunch I
suppose uh the IRA caused terror in the
UK for nearly a century the large army
in Africa why why focus simply on Islam
well you know I went to my uh podiatrist
the other day and I said why don't you
deal with heart trouble there's no
monopoly on evil
And there's no claim on my part that
only Muslims are terrorists or only the
terrorists are
Muslims. I don't know the Duck Dynasty
guy. I doubt that he's a very
influential leader. And I don't see
30,000 uh attacks by Christians
screaming Jesus is Lord around the world
since 9/11. But I do see 30,000 Islamic
jihad attacks. So certainly there are
evil people in every group who do all
sorts of evil things but this is a
problem that needs to be addressed and a
specialist in one problem is not denying
that there are other problems.
Uh hi yeah I just wanted to clarify
something in terms of the police your
followers ready to shoot a protester so
I took necessary precautions for that.
They're not here for you. They're here
to keep order. So, I mean, I think you
really think that
I'm trying to clarify something.
Um, I actually deny the charge. I don't
think that my followers threatened to
shoot anyone. There was we have
there was there was a comment on the
website and you know anybody can write
comments and I don't know who those
people are and I know from many great
deal of experience that there are many
many people who try to discredit the
site who are actually on the other side
of the perspective they are representing
themselves to be in any case I don't
approve of any such activity I was
certainly threatened and that was quite
clear and I don't approve of any threats
to you or Anybody else?